hi I'm Erik Bosse and I'm Philip Molina
and adventures the in-game concluded
with the most epic crossover battle
sequence that hatched open every MCU
Easter open past 11 years and scramble
them into an omelet that we loved 3,000
so we had to split our freaking Avengers
and game break down into two in depth
halves so this is part two right now go
check out part 1 if you haven't already
for all the miserable details in that
artful way the filmmakers set up this
part of the finale
honestly this all plays like its own
movie so it's worthy of its own video
analyzing it spoiler warning in case we
ruin your life with this analysis let's
pick up where we left off The Avengers
having returned from their time heist
six Infinity stones richer but one black
widow poorer and then Thor wants to use
the stones to bring her back but Clint
assures him nah dawg it can't be done
last episode we actually explained how
an game's description of Boromir as the
center of celestial existence could hint
at maybe a connection to the marble
Celestials which would make the blood
sacrifice for the soul stone
irreversible stark designs his own
Infinity Gauntlet which unlike Thanos is
gauntlet goes on the righthand sanest is
using his left hand to destroy half of
all life and the avengers are using
their right hand to bring it back it's
another example of the spiritual
undercurrent of infinity war an endgame
left-handedness and judeo-christian
tradition was once seen as wrong and
evil they used to force unfortunate
left-handed kids to use a right hand so
we've come a long way since the power of
the Infinity stones is a godly power it
makes sense for Starks who identify his
gauntlet as the one to set the universe
back on the right path
so then Thor volunteers to use the
gauntlet claiming to be the strongest
avenger that's a might Thor impression
it's nothing perfect this is a callback
to Ragnarok when Thor tries to identify
himself to the Quinjet as strongest
Bendrick strongest avenger then banner
logs in and the computer is like yeah
strongest avenger oh staying true to
that it's banner slash Hulk who steps up
and he reminds us that the stones emit
gamma radiation which is the same
radiation that gave him his powers and
that maybe banner was born exactly for
this moment this connection was
established way back in the first
Avengers when Nick Fury brought in Bruce
Banner because
of his gamma radiation detection
technology that could be used to track
Loki's movement with the stones Banner
screams as a gauntlet and stones burn
his arm and the others considered taking
it off but cap checks in with them
asking if he can handle it
this recalls a moment of caps
supercharged experiment in his first
movie when he screamed in agony and
Tony's father Howard almost shut it all
down the cap screamed back so while this
is happening nebula who is actually her
evil 2014 self who snuck back into the
present with the others she uses the
quantum tunnel to beam up Thanos his
entire warship from the past now to
clear up any confusion yes the Avengers
were only supposed to have enough Pym
particles for a round trip for
themselves alone but according to the
filmmakers evany MA is like a brilliant
scientist and anything they need him to
be apparently he could reverse
engineered the Pym particle technology
from 2014 nebulas stolen vial and they
could use that to bring Thanos his ship
his black order and his entire army to
the future so even though Banner is
successful in snappy and everyone back
we don't get to enjoy it for too long
the asthenosphere enters HQ and you know
let's take a moment to compare this
Thanos to who Thanos was an infinity war
Thanos came in to infinity war already
accomplishing the unprecedented feat of
collecting two Infinity stones that
makes Thanos kind of a zen-like deity
throughout that movie he takes off his
armor he cries at one point he tells
Stark I hope they remember you he tells
Wanda this guy's empathy wants to retire
on a farm and you know he killed vision
which you know some of us were actually
kind of okay with dad is not ok but
hurry
but this 2014 Thanos is still a hungry
hungry war monger he's younger he's
stronger still armored still packin
farming he still wants blood and his
response to learning his future snap
doesn't lead to a grateful universe is
to tear this universe to shreds and
start over kill everyone
much like the one-dimensional sob that
Thanos is in the comics hey these are a
lot of judgments again
Santos Santos I think that you have a
point anyway in the ruins of hate you
thatõs did nothing if you did something
in the ruins of their HQ banner slash
Hulk holds up a huge chunk of rubble to
protect rody and rocket just like the
comics image actually from Secret Wars
number four and that leaves stark cap
and Thor on the surface which I kind of
like the holy Marvel Trinity yeah
they're the ones that are left to
confront the mad Titan so when Thor
charges up his combined power of
Stormbreaker and meow-meow his shaggy
beard twists into that sweet braid of a
Norse God the fight choreography of this
three-on-one fight is filled with
callbacks to marvel past thor blasts
lightning in a stark suit which stark
uses to supercharge his repulsors just
like thor accidentally did with his
lightning in the first Avengers and
Thanos pins Thor pushing Stormbreaker
into his chest
a reversal of when Thor didn't go forth
a nose has had an infinity war and of
course the most epic visual this movie
the rise of new year on there wielded by
Captain America Thor Cheers
I knew it because this is a callback to
the test of strength and age of Ultron
when cap slightly blood spill near
causing Thor to briefly freak out that
someone else might be worthy you know I
like to think that cap could have lifted
Mjolnir in that moment but he decided to
hold back to spare Thor's pride
apparently when Thor loses fried he
loses his workout routine and turns into
melted ice cream then cap tosses his
shield and throws me on the air into it
creating a powerful calm shockwave that
knocks Thanos off his feet he's calling
back actually that same team-up move
with him and Thor back in age of Ultron
but Thanos four years younger remember
for years hotter
he's more battle hungry than his older
self was he beats down all three of them
in this moment and he breaks caps field
which is a nod not only to the Infinity
Gauntlet comics but we're finally seeing
the nightmare vision that Tony had way
back in age of Ultron that's all in the
surroundings here the rubble the coming
leviathans all the visuals are Starks
worst fears becoming realized baños
assembles his full army including the
Black Order and the Chitauri the
leviathans cap gets to his feet and
faces Thanos alone another epic visual
from the Infinity Gauntlet comics the
moment captain blimp stopped at Thanos
and says as long as one man stands
against you thinnest you'll never be
able
claimed victory but then back up the
voice of Sam Wilson comes in saying on
your left
I'll call back to captain falcon's
recurring line from Winter Soldier on
your left and at the end of the movie
Sam greets old man cap on his left get
it yes says he's more liberal so then
the sling ring portals from dock strange
and Wong open and they return
pretty much everyone who's available to
the battle we're talking Black Panther
we're talking Sheree a co a from makanda
they're joined by the combined tribal
forces with mbaku chaining a bombe their
battle cry from infinity war that
translates to hold fast Bucky and Groot
also of course joined them Doctor
Strange brings in Drac stand mantis and
star-lord and Peter Parker all from
Titan and the remaining Asgardian
soldiers we're talking cord meek
Valkyrie on her breaking Pegasus
alongside Scarlet Witch on nothing plus
all of the Sorcerer's that Wang could
gather who've been dying and behind her
freaking Howard the Duck wielding some
massive gun he comes in with a bunch of
the Ravagers from guardians of the
galaxy and of course Pepper Potts
wearing finally the blue-colored stark
armor a nod to her rescue incarnation in
the comics
she's even there too pushing goop on all
of us it's everybody cap sees everyone
and says Avengers a symbol paying off
that t's at the end of age of Ultron
when he didn't say it and he says it
while holding Mjolnir it evokes the
image from the fear itself comics when
he says that strange says to Wong is
that everyone at Wong's spike you wanted
more it's great meta not for Marvel to
the fans who this might probably feeling
pretty overwhelmed with joy in this
moment there's probably some of you
looking for daredevil and Punisher and
feeling disappointed the screenwriters
actually said that they considered
bringing in the Marvel Netflix defenders
University arrows but in the end they
needed to pay off faces from the Marvel
films and choosing this moment to
introduce characters from shows that may
be sizable portions of the film
audiences didn't watch well probably
just feel weird but Howard the Duck
everybody recognizes Howard the Duck
right right so then the battle features
highlight after highlight after a
highlight it's like you have to watch it
30 times to catch all these things Scott
Lang as giant man is punching a
Leviathan Falcon uses his
wings to stab a beast which is the only
move I want Falcon to use from now on
tracks quick stabs of beast with his
daggers like he did in the stomach
lining of the obelisk and guardians to
Lord makes cap swap Stormbreaker from me
linear because he's got to take the
small one
one great callback that came up is when
hope and I'm radio to cap saying we're
on it cap and then Scott gives her this
knowing look it's actually a callback to
the joke in a man and the wasp when hope
is mocking Scott for thinking he's on
this nickname basis with Steve Rogers
cap needed helps to America captain
cap it's it's what we call it while this
is going on Starks gauntlet trades
handsome Avenger to Avenger like a
football and a rush to the goal line
this was actually foreshadowed in the
earlier scene with stark and nebula
flicking folded footballs on the Benatar
the position goes from Hawkeye to 2014
nebula a similar to the moment nebula
possesses the gauntlet of comics then
back to Hawkeye black panther then to
spider-man spider-man with an assister
Valkyrie Captain Marvel before theaters
to start wrestle over 8 but when Black
Panther takes it he says Clint pass me
the gauntlet a nod to their first
interaction in Civil War I'm pleased I
don't care when peter has gone when he
finally activates instant kill mode
function in this suit that he was too
afraid to use in spider-man homecoming
activating instant kill no no no I don't
wanna kill anybody and when Carroll gets
the gauntlet from spider-man he
introduces himself as Peter Parker
keeping with this habit of telling
everyone his actual name
I'm Peter by the way Doctor Strange all
your made-up names um I'm spider-man
then I like Tom Hall and it just
improvised as most of it cap does call
Peter Queens which is a nod to their
first interaction in civil war guard kid
are you from please
Brooklyn and we got to talk about the
hog Tony Stark gives him Peter sighs
this feels nice which is a nod to the
fake hug that mr. stark gave him in
spider-man homecoming that's not a hug
and just grab the door for you star-lord
also gets rescued by Gamora who's her
2014 self and has not met Peter quill
yet so she needs them in the balls twice
calling back a moment that they met ins
and R in the first guardians when Gamora
kicked quill in the you know lower
abdomen which any guy knows is almost as
bad because it kind of like mix it yeah
it's a ripple effect ripple effect yeah
Scarlet Witch confronts Thanos snarling
you took everything for me
Stannis is like I have no idea you are
she's like you will there's actually
some poetic justice in the precise way
that Wanda and the Avengers avenge
Thanos in the Black Order we'll get to
it later but one has beat down forces
Thanos to order his worship to reign
fire they'll take cover rocketjump son
grew to protect him these two have
always been close but James Gunn
revealed that groots final rocket as he
dusted away and if any war translated to
dad it had to be the most painful thing
you can say
Captain Marvel then destroys the ship
joining Scarlet Witch a coy about Corey
pepper potts mantis Shuri wasp and
Gamora it's an all-female badass lineup
to loose not actually to the a force in
the Marvel Comics which is the first
all-female Avengers lineup from the
Secret Wars era that included she hauled
Dazzler Nico Minoru Medusa Carol Danvers
actually joins later during this Drive
you can briefly see a co a get the kill
on Corvus glaive of thanasis black order
of been gene finally the Dorma logic
guards that Corvis killed back in
shuri's lab in infinity war during this
melee stark checks in with dr. strange
who initially won't confirm for Stark if
this is the one of the 14 million 6005
future outcome said he foresaw an
infinity war in which they one worried
that this wish future won't come true if
he tells Tony but right at the end
strange holds up one finger to Stark and
you'll notice his hand Quivers which is
a nice physical touch from Benedict
Cumberbatch who vibrates his hands like
this whenever he conjures spells since
remember the muscles and tendons have
strangest hands were all physically
damaged in the car accident so
in addition to confirming to start that
this is the one Victoria's future
Strange's echoing the promise that Stark
made to strange after strange save his
life on Titan an infinity war oh you
want and this one that Stark Oh strange
is the sacrifice play that will ensure
this victory happens so it's the final
face-off between Thanos and stark and
Thanos tries to snap the minds is not
very effective he turns over the
gauntlet to find the stones are missing
and that turning over and seeing that
the gauntlet is not effective right now
that's a callback to what rocket did at
the beginning in Thanos farmhouse
realizing oh god let's empty stones are
gone and turns out what happened is that
Stark used his nanotech armor to absorb
the stones into his own armor distort
gauntlet is connected to the same
network of nanobots that his suit is so
an infinity war who was actually a
subtle hint toward this when stark took
off his sunglasses in New York as a
nanotech armor spread all over body it
absorbed the sunglasses have you noticed
and then strike response if Thanos
saying I am inevitable with a callback
to his classic badass moment at the end
of his first movie I am Iron Man so
Stark snaps away all of the noses forces
and this snap derp math mirrors the
ending of Infinity Ward Danno sits
weakened just like he did on the farm in
the final shot infinity war behind him
every Mach watches his stomach and limps
toward him exactly how Peter Parker
didn't feel so good with Stark on Titan
ebony moss-like sorry and further in the
background Proxima midnight kneels
beside the body of her husband Corvus
glaive yes they are actually married
it's recreating the silhouette of Wanda
holding visions body and infinity war so
what a maksimov receives her poetic
justice just in a very cold
eye-for-an-eye kind of way so the impact
blast of the snap itself as we saw with
Hulk and Thanos is just too much for a
Tony start to handle and his final
moments are a true emotional gut punch
Peter Parker and all of us are sobbing
as he watches them fade actually a
reversal at the end of Infinity Ward arc
watching Peter fade also Pepper Potts
tells him it's okay you can rest now
earlier in the film she told Tony he
wouldn't be able to sleep if he didn't
try to fix the snap now that he has he
can finally sleep he can rest
Tony making this sacrifice pays off the
argument he and cap had way back in the
first Avengers
you're not the guy to make the sacrifice
play
but cap wasn't the only one wrong in
that same scene stark tells cap
everything special about you me my
bottle
so both the vengers actually proved the
other one wrong start made the sacrifice
play and cap by wielding Mele near
proved he does possess an innate power
underneath his lab enhanced utterly
amazing physique he's got worthiness in
there this whole movie led to this
moment
starix goodbye message to pepper on the
Benatar foreshadowed scarring and damage
to his right side and the wiping of a
tear and I'm sure there's a tinfoil
interpretation in this movie in which
Tony actually did die on the Benatar and
the glowing arrival of Captain Marvel
was an angel giving him this chance to
live in a perfect afterlife having a kid
with pepper on a farm cracking the code
of time-travel and saving everyone so
within games plot is a little too crazy
for you there you guys just all the
dream of a dying man but this movies
ending returns to that post-mortem
goodbye projected from the Iron Man
helmet and echoes Howard Stark leaving
behind a message for Tony an Iron Man 2
what is and always will be my greatest
creation
is human and start says if you told me
years ago that we weren't alone in the
universe I wouldn't have believed to the
extent of it to someone at the moment
Nick Fury recruited Stark to join the
Avengers mr. stark you've become part of
a bigger universe you just don't know it
Starks funeral Dan shows his old arc
reactor if that's proof Tony Stark has a
heart it was actually given to him by
pepper in the first Ironman and the
music composed by Alan Silvestri here
it's plain over the final minutes it
actually was teased earlier and just
throughout the movie for instance you
could hear it with Tony when he's kind
of fading away at the benatar it plays
any time that you're supposed to realize
Tony is a mortal man who might die or
ultimately even he does die though
then everybody shows up at his funeral
and it's all the familiar faces but a
lot of people were like Wayne uh who's
that dude that one unfamiliar face
that's Harley keiner the kid from
Tennessee Fat Tony met in Iron Man 3
with ty Simpkins actually returning for
his role happy Hogan sits with Morgan
who says that she wants cheeseburgers a
callback to the only food Tony wanted to
eat after returning in the first Ironman
you remember that Burger King
cheeseburger was actually a meta
reference to Robert Downey jr. real life
recovery from his drug addiction he said
once when he was high he ordered a
disgusting burger and a soda and he
panicked that something really bad was
gonna happen so he end up throwing all
the drugs in his car into the ocean and
then got cleaned up he said Burger King
saved his life but I don't imagine
Burger King likes to hear this story
also if you're gonna throw out your
drugs great but you know somewhere
besides the open ocean take those whales
that calf spotted in Hudson are on crack
so Clint still feels bad about Natasha
and he tells Wanda she knows that we won
Wanda replies they both do referencing
visions another major Avenger who
unfortunately did not get to come back
in this movie but they will both
actually be appearing in the Disney Plus
Series Wanda vision so you can look
forward to that somehow getting figured
out and showing up again
montage then chose Peter Parker
returning to school and reuniting with
Ned so it appears that Ned is probably
the same age or just aging real well but
it would probably suggest that he also
was probably dusted in fact just going
out on a limb here and saying maybe all
of the characters that are gonna appear
in spider-man far from home they
probably are all happened to be people
that also were dusted MJ flash Betty
Brant
none of them appear to be five years
older and anything we've seen but well
dig into endgames connection to far from
home and if you
and Thor joins the guardians of the
galaxy undercutting Peter Quill's
Authority as he did an infinity war
except now Thor is the overly one
flipping the fat jokes away from quill
as they were before a muscular who are
you kidding
well you're one sandwich away from fat
yeah right it's true what and that
brings us to caps mysterious mission to
return the Infinity stones to their
proper places in the timeline for he
jumps he tells Bucky don't do anything
stupid until I get back and Bucky
responds how can i you've taken all the
stupid with you which is the callback to
their exchange in the first cat movie
don't do anything stupid until I get
back how can I taking all the stupid
with you
so endgame doesn't show us caps return
trip and for good reason because it's
kind of nuts to think about what he
would have had to do to put all those
stones back some of them would have been
like simple swaps sure put the sour
stone back in the temple keep the
time stone back to the agent once she
gets it put the space stone back in the
shield basement but that also means cap
had to give the scepter with the mine
stone back to Hydra which could not have
been easy for him to do they probably
murdered millions of things also really
weird yet to reinsert the ether back
into Jane Foster on Asgard which was a
very awkward conversation at the least
right yeah like a lady a raccoon just
took this out of you and I'm gonna shove
this open your mind Green sludge beckon
you drink it drink it we have no idea
actually we do full disclosure guys
Philip and I actually do know what
happened on CAPS return trip we went
back in time to part 1 of this video
when I still had the Infinity Gauntlet
remember that we sold the gauntlet from
our past selves and we use the gauntlets
infinite power to see hold the weird
stuff that cap really did in the past is
just too awful to discuss like we don't
want to ruin your memory a cap yeah
apparently everyone in the 1940s was not
a good person by today's standards yeah
also I finally understand why he did not
want to tell Sam what he's been up to it
was not good oh yeah no but let's
discuss this mystery of the soul stone
since you get the soul stone by
sacrificing a loved one when you return
the soul stone do you get that loved one
back do you have to take him back if you
didn't really miss your loved one that
much is it a matter of just throwing the
stone back into that
kinda like job trying to throw the
letter back into the ocean this could be
one way black widow could still be alive
but it's worth considering the
possibility that cap might have kept the
soul stone as like a safeguard against
anyone trying to wring out of the stones
in this new timeline that he's in or
maybe returning the soul stone gave him
his soul back in a metaphorical way
allowing them to return to the 1940s and
live out his life with Peggy Carter his
soul mate yeah either way the Russos
deed confirmed that caps new life with
Peggy Carter that all happened in a
separate timeline apparently old cap is
showing up back in this timeline at the
end of the movie through some other
mysterious means that they said could
get addressed in a future film where
they'll retcon people but let's actually
talk about old man cap here he passes on
the mantle of Captain America to Sam not
Bucky which surprised many of you and
many of us but Bucky gives Sam this
understanding like knowing nod since old
cap came from a different timeline maybe
in that reality Bucky already did serve
as Captain America I can't actually
imagine a scenario where cap went back
to the 40s and it would let his best
friend just spend 50 years being
brainwashed and tortured inside their
every Hydra but it turns out yeah I kept
did some crazy stuff you think you know
a hero yeah so maybe Steve and Bucky did
have a lifetime of adventures under the
captain america name maybe it didn't go
so well when he picked Bucky yeah maybe
Bucky doesn't want it yeah I'm making
Bucky just reveals that it's not great
to give it to a Russian assassin ya know
by terrorists make him Captain America
either way he decides in this timeline
he wants Sam to have a turn
hopefully the upcoming Falcon and Winter
Soldier series on Disney Plus will
actually dive into this maybe rivalry
Junior when old cap hands off his shield
to Sam notice how he removes it from
this artists portfolio case miss Steve
Rogers did and some of the classic
comics actually this is a nod to Steve's
interest in sketching which we actually
saw him do briefly in the first movie
and in a deleted sequence of the first
Avengers that sequence explored just how
melancholy and out of place cap felt as
a soldier removed from its time so it's
particularly satisfying to know that
Steve was able to return and live the
life that he always wanted when sam asks
him about Peggy he's
his memories to himself similar to the
way Tom Hanks his World War 2 captain if
Saving Private Ryan did refusing to talk
about his wife so finally the closing
scene shows cap and Peggy slow dancing
in their home back in the 1940s Matt
finally does take Peggy up on that rain
check that he left with her way back in
the personal you actually might
recognize this slow song it's called
it's been a long long time and it's a
favorite of caps back in Winter Soldier
Sharon Carter Peggy's great niece told
Steve he left his stereo on and Nick
Fury was playing that exact song in his
apartment as a way to cover their
conversation from being recorded real
quick the fact that cap had kind of a
thing with Sharon Carter I hope didn't
come up with her auntie Peggy Carter
it was sweet it was innocent he's just
you know getting goodness kicks and if
you actually look into the history of
this song this recording was by Harry
James and with vocals by Kitty Callen it
was a huge hit in 1945 because the
lyrics are from the perspective of a
woman welcoming home her loved one
returning from the war this is during a
time when many American spouses were
embracing their returning soldiers and
the way this woman embraces her soldier
returning from a very distant
battlefield so Avengers endgame is
actually a story about destinations and
trajectories and the two figures at the
center of the story Tony Stark
and Steve Rogers they began these films
at complete opposite ends of the
continuum tony was kind of a selfish
prick and steepest insufferably selfless
as a Boy Scout but an in-game these two
heroes set off in the boldest
trajectories of their lives
Tony gives up his perfect life with his
family to go on a mission that he
probably knows will take his life he
lays on the wire Steve for the first
time really excel fish Lee he wants a
life with Peggy so he treats himself to
one but before he does that he carries
the burden of putting the world back
together
Steve's destination is enlightened
self-interest Tony's destination is
selflessness and both Avengers bullseye
there in games it's the exact same
journey Eric and I have been on all
these years
down below with your favorite moment
from a vendor's endgame and be sure to
watch part 1 of this breakdown if you
haven't already we covered so many
details in it the filmmakers hid so much
in every single scene also by the way
like not just Easter eggs and stuff but
the interesting filmmaking tricks and
visuals that make endgame this really
rich movie going experience bigger than
any movie we've ever seen subscribe to
new rockstars we do deep dives into
everything that you love Marvel's Star
Wars game of Thrones DC even like Pixar
movies horror films Marvel Marvel more
Marvel and sometimes classic beloved
movies that you still re-watch here
after a year like we'll show you all the
cool stuff that you might have
overlooked in all of those movies and
make sure to subscribe to our new
podcast feed it's called inside Marvel
it gives you early access to all of our
Marvel breakdowns and theory videos some
of that upcoming content is also just
audio only bonus content and even these
kinds of things they come out there
first so if you're hungry for it then
you better subscribe follow me on
Twitter at fimo and on instagram at
philip molina and follow me on instagram
and twitter at EA boss thank you for
watching and oh we got to go back in
time and go fix all the disgusting
things that cat did all right well each
pose is our favorite Avenger and then
set him straight
great - great oh we probably should have
coordinated better how dare you point at
me you're pointing at me it's rude to
point you are being very rude
[Music]